[Music]
hello you took just love us and my
friends this is guns in here
welcome to the 49th episode of dirty
tricks in this episode I'm going to show
you some of the wonderful tricks and
traps exist in the xn Slough from the
white perspective the opening arises
after the following model defo defy c4
c6 and now white exchange in the center
with C captors D Phi and C captures defy
okay the main line continues with Knight
to c3 and the important point I like to
highlight here that if black continue
with inaccurate move Knight to c6 then
white has this little break efore and
you can check it out the database where
white has scored some great victories so
accordingly black needs to stop it and
that's why the main line continues wait
Knight to f6 restricting the e full moon
and we reach to a very critical junction
of the theory when I was researching
about this line I have gone through some
books and the DVDs and to my surprise
most of the books and DVDs has concern
only two moves namely Knight to f3 and
Bishop to f4 however as usual in my
videos I always deliver the surprise
package and this video is not apart from
edge as here I am going to recommend a
very rare but very effective Bishop to
g5 oh well
is very simple in many lines whitewalls
to capture this night which is a
supporter of the defy pond and then
immediately put pressure on this defy
and b7 pawn especially if black
prematurely take out his light square
bishop which happens in many Slough
lines now as I have highlighted over
here black has tried four options and
let's see each bite on the phosphor I
want to consider is Bishop to a5 which
looks very natural and many Slav defense
player will play it except against
Bishop to g5 it's a bit problematic
because up to the simple capture Bishop
captures up six it doesn't matter
however a black recapture
let's say G captures up six why it has
these sneaky tactics Queen to b3 hitting
to sports and black
in fact cannot defend what the ball so
even though eunjin suggests that white
is slightly better if you think about
practical point of view this position
always favors the white the second more
I want to consider is Knight to c6 which
in fact the highest Lee played more in
this position and after that we are
going to continue with III well if black
plays here a six then his bishop will be
tremendously bad so accordingly we are
looking at the lines where black tried
to get out this bishop before he closed
down with a six once again at this
position Bishop to a5 is a wrong move
the simple reason is yep you got it
very simple Bishop captures up six G
captures up six and now Queen to b3 and
the same tactics work this time as well
so it is very clear
here that black still cannot take out
that bishop so many educated Slough
player comes up with this a six moon
just waiting for the right moment to
take that bishop out well here my
recommendation is you should play the
move Queen to b3 and again our threat is
very simple we want to take this nine
and then take on do you fire a black
plays a six then once again you can see
the difference or light square bishop
has not been obstructed where black
light square bishop is completely jumped
in so accordingly
that is one move which helps black to
take out his bishop and that is Knight
to e5 attacking the Queen Queen to c2
very nice move stopping Bishop to fr as
well as Knight to e4 idea by black but
black is more than happy as he can
continue with now Bishop to g4 taking
out that big tower then closing on with
ecigs
and black is a happy chappy right hahaha
nope that's not simple as in many cases
White has some sneaky tactics in the
picture and accordingly here white
continue with h3 hitting the bishop a
bishop goes back to d7 then we have no
problem the bishop remains passing so
more critical responses what happens
after Bishop to h5 well at first sight
this variation looks completely harmless
for the black camp as it doesn't have
any problem to ticking out his light
square bishop but believe it a lord
after just one move black can see how
pitiable his position is and the movies
f4 so idea is very simple we want to
play g4 and then fr and trapping the
light square bishop and in two of my
games my opponent has continued with at
six which is a horrible
in this position as after the simple
continuation bishop catches up 6e
captures f6 and now probably they
thought that once I will play g4 they
can put the bishop back on at seven but
what they overlook is this move fi and
no matter however black riggers he is
going to lose a piece the third who I
want to consider is Knight to e4 which
in fact the third popular choice by
black but once again it fails to the
following sequence namely night cap to
c4 pawn captures a fool and now the
simple move looked to see even grabbing
the open file and looking at the week CH
spot well in the database most of the
games continue here with Knight to c6
attacking twice on d4 at same time
protecting the c8 bishop but I think
this is a wrong continuation the simple
reason is after defy attacking the
knight that poor knight cannot move the
simple reason is after quint we
forecheck white wins the pawn and in
fact the game so accordingly black has
to deliver this check so idea is very
simple if white blocked the check with
the bishop then the d5 pawn will be lost
but White has a better move namely Queen
to d2 and now in the view of hanging
Knight black is forced to exchange this
Queen Queen captures Bishop captures and
after Knight to e5 we reach to the
critical junction of this line where by
force wide gate of winning gauge with
push up to c3 attacking the knight black
doesn't want to play Knight to d7 as his
Bishop will be very cramped so
accordingly black and tried to move
Knight to g4 or Knight to g6 let's say
Knight to g4 but after that
why continue with the threatening move
III so Bishop to b5 as a threat which
misplaced the black King
so black needs to stop it with Bishop to
d7 afterwards a slightly surprising moon
looked an even haha and it's funny that
currently black cannot even free of his
dark squared Bishop with either a six or
g6 in order to do that black has to play
Knight to f6 to enable those moves
but now white can play Bishop to c4
completely stopping e6 idea and only
allowing the move g6 which actually
havens one of the game in the database
continued with rook to c8 attacking the
bishop Bishop to b3 and now indeed black
plays the move g6 thinking that nothing
is happening in this position but after
just one more oh the black position
completely collapse obviously you cannot
take on d6 as f6 Knight is hanging and
in the game black continued with the
obvious move Bishop to g7 which
obviously backfires with D captures e7
King kept to c7 Bishop to b4 checked
King to e8 rucola it is not a happy
chappie but what black can do and after
why it's next reply Knight to e2 it is
very obvious that black has a completely
missed coordination in his camp and on
top white is ready to Castle and
launched a devastation on the black King
which is Scott on the center of the ball
so so far we have seen that black has
tried various things to take out that
light square bishop but against Bishop
to g5 he is not able to do it so how
about a solid looking move ecigs
which again second most popular choice
by black and you will be amazed there
there are
some nasty trap exist in this line as
well first of all White's planning of
campaign is very simple he will continue
with III and after Bishop to e7 next to
step of the white is very simple he's
going to play Knight to f3 or Bishop to
d3 in either Mordor so for example in
one game white continue wait Knight to
f3 and after Knight to c6 Bishop to d3
happen on the board black castle on the
Kings side why does the same and now
here comes the problematic thing what to
do
to activate that poor bishop well most
logical continuation is p6
if you cannot activate on h3 see a
diagonal then the logical response is
play the b6 activate on b7 where it can
support Knight to e4 idea buy black all
looks great right yup but one problem
that after this more black is completely
losing yes you heard it right after this
move black is completely busted now
before I show it to you I want you to
pause this video and find out what is
wrong with this nature looking move b6
ok let's get started the first move is
very obvious Bishop captures f6
destroying the defender of the h7 square
and here by force black has to capture
with the Jeep on and even after that his
King will be wide open and white get all
the winning chances but the most
important question is black is not a
stupid he is obviously going to take
with the bishop right and what's wrong
in that
well here comes dancer who
we'll play the move Queen to c2
attacking on at seven and it doesn't
matter whether black continued with at
six or g6 the position is completely
lost before we look at it the first
question comes to the mind that well
hang on but what about Knight to be full
isn't that a great move attacking to
sports well here a white has a simple
sequence which gives him the winning
gauge Bishop to at seven King to h8 and
now after winning upon what has this
counter attacking move Quint way for if
King takes Bishop then Queen takes
Knight and white emerge with an extra
pawn but what about Knight captures a
two so now if you capture the knight
then black will capture the bishop and
once again the material is even guess
what white will still remain a pornog
after this deciding blow Knight captures
define what a move so idea is very
simple if black take this Bishop then
Knight captures f6 comes with a check
and then later on what will take this
piece and white will be a clear upon up
if black capture this noid either with
the pawn or the Queen let's say Queen
takes Knight then white has a simple
move Bishop to d3 and that poor Knight
is going to be captured on the next move
and at the end of the sequence white
emerge with extra pawn ok back to this
position where we were looking at what
happens if black plays the move
g6 did you spot it yup it's once again
this nice deciding blow based on this
lose knight on c6 Knight captures d5
well if simple black capture this night
then white queen will capture on c6 and
white will emerge with an extra pawn but
then what about win captures defy
supporting the night here the first move
is very obvious
Bishop to e4 we are insisting to getting
of a piece back so if the Queen
retrieved then c6 Knight will be lost so
the last try by black is Knight to be
full counter attacking your queen and
here rather than going into the
complications such as Bishop captures D
finite capture c2 which is in fact
somewhat okay for white I think the
better sequence is Queen to b1 and after
this move white get the piece back with
a decisive advantage last but not least
what happens if black continue it Knight
B to d7 let's see one example in this
game white continue with Bishop to d3
black castle on the Kings side like to
have three so this moves are very
obvious no change at all from the white
side and now in the last game we look at
Knight to c6 in this game black continue
with Knight B to d7 okay that doesn't
look so threatening so we are going to
castle on the King side and now Essex
trying to expand on the Queen side and
generally my recommendation against such
a structure is you definitely want to
consider the Stonewall attacks satyr
which start with Knight to f3 f4 and
then put this rook on the h3 square
where White has some nice attack going
on on the at 7 square which is not easy
to stop you can definitely check out
some games in the data base which will
give you a very good idea
how to create a King side attack and win
the game or very quickly however I like
to show you one nice trick which you
should definitely know if you
going to play this line in the
tournament practice in this game
white continue it rook to Sivan and
after the move be Phi he's a stop the B
for advanced by black with a three black
plays the national move look to heed so
idea is very simple that poorly placed
d7 nine will be routed on the g6 square
where it has some influence on the White
King side here
white continue with Bishop to f4 and the
trick is set right here any black player
who see this MOOC and easily understood
that white wants to play s3 and then
preserve the dark square Bishop so why
not play the move Knight to h5 so as
white has not played the match three you
can exploit this move and get the bishop
pair well yes the idea is right but I'm
sorry the execution is wrong as black
has fallen into the white tricky care
because white has this star move in the
position boom so all in all in many
lines white get this pawn advantage and
the big tactical point behind this that
if black captured this night then Bishop
to c7 and black Queen is a corner that's
it guys I hope you enjoy an on my mini
reputa of exchange Lau with this novelty
Bishop to g5 you can surprise lot of
your tournament opponent and as I have
shown in this video
it contains lot of tricks so you have
every chance to finish your opponent
very quickly and get the full point well
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care
you